Is it true that there's some huge
problem with the Trump administration
when it comes to pistol braces or is
there a lot of hyperbole going on in
social media right now? Well, a lot of
people have asked me to take a look at
this. So, I have done so and we're going
to break down what's the story with this
most recent filing by the Department of
Justice down there in the state of Texas
dealing with the pistol brace rule and
the National Firearms Act as applied to
so-called short barrel rifles. Let's
talk about it when we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
Forbox Adana, proud American gun owner,
constitutional attorney, member of the
United States Supreme Court Bar, and I'm
proud to say the top voice of the Second
Amendment in America. Thank you both
2025 and 2026 Gundies Awards. All right,
folks. So, a lot of people have been
asking me about this pistol brace issue.
Uh there's been a lot of news stories
about a recent filing by the United
States Department of Justice under Pam
Bonnie and Donald Trump. Uh basically
indicating that they intend to continue
to enforce the National Firearms Act as
applied to so-called short barrel rifles
or certain pistols or handguns that have
some sort of attachment to it. And is
this something that we should be
freaking out about? So, I've actually
because I was asked about this by enough
people, I decide to go ahead and take a
look at this myself. And frankly, I
don't quite understand the hub here. Uh,
and let me tell you why I say that.
We're going to get a little geeky here.
Now, remember, I've explained to you
right up front that to be the smartest
person in in in the room when it comes
to our Second Amendment rights and our
gun rights and all that stuff, you need
to understand not just substantive law.
What does the National Firearms Act say?
What does the gun control act say? What
does the second amendment mean? How does
it apply to a sensitive place case?
Right? You got to understand the
substantive law like the law of the
land. Okay? But you also need to
understand process. You need to
understand procedures because in many
respects the process and the procedures
if it's not done right or if it's a
different context can cause you to never
get to the question of what is the
substantive law. So, for example, just
to illustrate the point, then we'll
bring it back to this pistol brace
issue. If you remember in 20 uh20 there
was a big debate about the election and
Donald Trump and all these people
brought these lawsuits and most of them
if not all of them are essentially
kicked out on procedural grounds due to
let's say a lack of standing of the
parties and therefore federal courts
cannot exercise jurisdiction in those
cases because under article two I'm
sorry under article three of the United
States Constitution that creates the
supreme court and the federal judiciary
uh you have to have a case or
controversy for a federal court to have
the constitutional authority to hear the
case. And that gives rise to a lot of
issues like standing right in this
mooteness and whatnot to make sure
there's an actual case or controversy.
Now, in light of what I just said here,
you need to understand the process and
procedures because it plays a big role
in understanding some of these court
decisions, some of these court disputes.
And if you don't get the procedure right
or the procedure is not proper or you go
down one path versus another path, you
might not have an opportunity to be
heard on the merits of substantive
claim. So in the 2020 election fight,
basically none of those major lawsuits
involving whether or not uh the election
was done in an unoured way that could
have altered the outcome in favor of Joe
Biden, let's say. Um well, you know,
because the process uh was not according
to Hoy, according to the courts, that's
what they said. Uh you never got to the
question in most of these courts of
whether or not shenanigans occur. But
that's just kind of illustrating the big
point. So with that said, let's turn to
this current case of the state of Texas,
Gun Owners of America versus the BATF.
Now, let's start from the good news.
We're gonna start from the good news,
then we're going to break down the facts
as I see it. The great news is that Joe
Biden's anti-gun Department of Justice
and ATF tried to screw American gun
owners when it came to possessing a
pistol with a stabilizing brace
attached. And what they tried to do was
to create this multiriteria,
multiffactor criteria designed
specifically, in my opinion, to capture
as many uh pistols with so-called
stabilizing braces as possible under the
net of the National Firearms Act to
increase the number of people and to
increase the number of guns that needed
to be registered and and have a $200 tax
stamp paid for. among other things under
the National Firearms Act. And the huge
win here, and we must give complete
props to the various groups and the
various people that brought these
lawsuits, including but not limited to
the gun owners of America. The reality
is they kicked the butt. They destroyed
and kicked the dupa of the Biden
administration on this pistol brace
nonsense. It's been wiped out.
Destroyed. Bye-bye. Fantastic news. We
should be spiking the ball in the end
zone. We should be tossing our bat
toward the dugout after hitting a home
run. Pick the metaphor you want. Huge
win. And that rule is gone bye-bye.
Fantastic. Now, now we're going to start
to segue into the issue today. How was
that final rule promagated by Joe Biden
where he basically had his ATF and
Department of Justice take a look at the
National Firearms Act, which is a
congressional statute, right? The
National Firearms Act, rightly or
wrongly, we don't like it, but it's
technically the law of the land today.
It is a statute that is on the books
right now that people have to follow.
And if you don't follow the National
Firearms Act, you could go to prison
potentially. Okay. Biden tried to
through the process of regulations
of rulemaking with the ATF tried to
expand the scope of the definition of
what is a short barrel rifle under the
National Firearms Act statutory
definition. He tried to expand the scope
of that definition, but he didn't try to
do it by going to Congress to enact a
broader law that expanding the scope of
the National Firearms Act. Instead, what
Biden did with his Department of Justice
is they went through rulemaking or the
creation of regulations that have
nothing to do with Congress and tried to
expand the definition of what is a short
bell rifle by virtue of how he defined
pistols with stabilizing braces. And the
court said this is not allowed. Now, we
got to get geeky. When you sue in
federal court for a remedy, you want the
court to do something. You want the
court to issue an order and a judgment
in your favor. Sometimes you ask for
money. Sometimes you want injunctive
relief that says the government cannot
enforce a law against you. Sometimes
maybe you want a restraining order
against someone that says, "Don't come
near me." Whatever it is, that is called
the remedy or the relief you want. When
you sue in court, you want something
from the court. You want the court to do
something. We want the court to enter an
order telling him to give me back my
bicycle, whatever it is. You see what
I'm saying? Okay. Now, when you're
dealing with, listen carefully, when
you're dealing with allegations or
arguments that a regulation such as the
one that Joe Biden's D at uh ATF
promulgated this final rule associated
with stabilizing braces. Okay. When
you're dealing with an argument in court
that a regulation has exceeded the scope
of the authority that the administrative
agency such as the ATF, which is an
administrative agency,
if the administrative agency has
exceeded the scope of its authority
under the enabling statute or whatever
it is, you sue in federal court under a
law known as the APA, which stands for
the administrative procedural act.
You use the APA to sue to argue in
federal court that this administrative
agency here, the ATF did something with
its regulations that exceeded the lawful
authority that the ATF had to do what it
did.
And that's what happened here in this
particular case that is the subject of
all this news attention. Um, this case
of State of Texas and Gun Owners America
versus the ATF. If you look at pages,
I'm I only looked at the original
complaint. If there may amend, we can
talk about that in a minute, but I
looked at pages 124 uh through 126 of
the original complaint. And you'll see
that all the causes of action and all
the arguments against this final rule
focus on the final rule. If you look at
it, it says, for example, uh plaintiffs
respectfully request that the court
declare that the final rule violates the
APA. Number two, declare that the final
rule violates the APA. Again, number
three, declare that the final rule
violates the APA as arbitrary and
capriccious. Number four, declare the
final rule violates the APA again. APA
stands for Administrative Procedural
Act. Number five, declare the final rule
violates the Administrative Procedure
Act or the APA again. Number six,
declare the final rule violates the
right to keep of arms. Number seven,
violates the fifth amendment's
privilege. Number eight, violates due
process. And it goes on and on and on.
Now, the thing to focus on there is that
every one of those wherefor clauses asks
that the final rule go bye-bye. That the
final rule get thrown to the dash into
the dust bin of history. Bye-bye.
That has now occurred. There's no
dispute. Everyone agrees, including the
government, including the Trump
administration, that this final rule of
Joe Biden's that expanded the definition
of what is a stabilizing brace plus
pistol that equals a short barrel rifle
under the National Firearms Act that
must be registered. That rule and
regulation by Biden has been destroyed
because it has been vacated under the
doctrine of Vocator. And the reason why
that's important is because under the
Administrative Procedural Act, which
I've just referred to repeatedly, the
APA or the Administrative Procedural
Act, the remedy you seek when you want a
court to say the rule can no longer be
enforced is the remedy you're seeking is
the remedy of vacation or vocs
that we want that rule that was
unlawfully promulgated, that was
unlawfully issued by the Biden
administration. We want that vacated as
if it was never there.
For those Latin majors out there, you
would vacate a rule nunk pro tunk, which
means basically from its init in
inception. Right? So again here that
final rule of the stabilizing braces has
indeed been vacated. Nump pro tunk. It's
over. Bye-bye. See you.
So now you turn back to the complaint
and the argument as to what you want in
this lawsuit. And it seems to me that
now that the final rule is gone, the
case is now what's known as moot because
the remedy that you wanted was to use
the administrative procedural act to
have a rule declared vacant or vacated
or bye-bye has occurred. The rule's no
more.
So that should be the end of end of the
story from a litigation point of view.
as I see it now. The ATF in their brief
said kind of a very pedestrian comment
as I read it. Specifically, they said,
"But of course, we're going to continue
to enforce as we need to, as
appropriate, the National Firearms Act
as a congressional statute because under
article two of the United States
Constitution,
the executive branch of the president
and his executive agencies, including
the ATF and the Department of Justice,
take a look at article two of the US
Constitution." Remember, article one of
the Constitution creates the Congress,
sets forth congressional powers. Article
two of the constitution creates the
presidency and executive authority and
executive agencies and whatnot. Right?
And article three creates the supreme
court and lower court says created by
congress. The reason why I want to
remind you of that is the US
constitution itself literally says in
article two that creates the white house
that creates the president that creates
the regulatory agency all that kind of
stuff. Okay. Conceptually, it
specifically says that the president and
the executive branch must take care to
faithfully execute the laws of the
federal government, the laws of the
land. And because the National Firearms
Act, rightly or wrongly, you know, I
don't like it. I don't want it to be
here. But I'm not here to blow smoke up
your dupa. I'm not rainbows and
unicorns. I'm here to tell you as I see
the reality on the ground. Even if it's
bad, I have to tell it to you because
that does you no good if I diagnose the
problem and it's wrong because I'm
blowing smoke up your dupa does not help
anybody in the real world. Okay? And the
reality is because the National Firearms
Act remains law today. It is legitimate
law right here and right now. Even if we
don't like it, it is the law right now.
And because article 2 of the
constitution tells the executive branch,
which is where the ATF and the DOJ
falls, they must take care to faithfully
execute today's laws. And one of those
laws is the National Firearms Act. All
this brief as I read is is saying that
we're the DOJ. We're going to continue
to enforce the National Firearms Act
because it's the law of the land and we
have a duty to do so. And basically,
we're there's nothing else to be done.
If if if there's a particular case down
the road involving an individual in
Montana, a ch su, you know, either sued
for violating the uh the NFA or is
indicted for violating the NFA or
someone brings a lawsuit against the ATF
that says, I've got this brand new
stabilizing brace and I want this to be
declared as not a short barrel rifle.
whatever it is, if that were to occur,
that fight should occur factually
in some other court, in some other case
when that specific problem comes up. So,
all that's happening here, as I see it,
is DOJ is just saying the NFA is still
the law. We reserve the right to
continue to enforce it as appropriate
against weapons that we think are indeed
short barrel rifles because it's our job
and that's it. And they are going on to
say that this particular lawsuit is
moot. It's over. You've won everything
you wanted. You wanted this rule to go
away, the final rule of Joe Biden, and
it's gone. You've won.
Now, with that said, that doesn't mean
that we in the Second Amendment
community cannot take other shots at the
National Firearms Act because to me, the
right way to go after the National
Firearms Act is already occurring by
lawyers and other courts. Now, remember
how I told you this particular case used
the process of the Administrative
Procedural Act to destroy the final rule
and regulation on the grounds that ATF
exceeded its authority under the
statute. And that's how you do it. But
there's another vehicle that would be
appropriate for going after the National
Firearms Act in various ways, and that
is the federal statute 42 USC 1983,
those civil rights statutes. So when you
sue in federal court, the state of New
York, when you sue in federal court,
some police agency, some cop, some
locality, whatever it is, you're suing
in federal court over a violation of the
Second Amendment or a violation of
article one of the Constitution that
they say Congress to pass the law that
doesn't have a whatever it is, you use
usually 42 USC 1983, which is a
different tool, a different mechanism
than the APA to get into federal court.
So, think about a toolbox. Sometimes you
need to hammer a nail. You use a hammer.
That is a different tool than a wrench
or a screwdriver.
So, too is the Administrative Procedural
Act a different legal tool to get into
federal court to challenge federal
actions or state or local actions than
42 USC 1983. If you're going to argue
that the National Firearms Act in some
way violates the Second Amendment or
violates the commerce clause or lacks a
tax connection because the one big
beautiful bill got rid of the tax of 200
bucks. So therefore there's no
connection between the NFA is applied to
short barrel rifles, short barrel
shotguns and suppressors and the taxing
authority because there is no tax that
is all done outside of the vehicle of
the APA. It's a different way a
different tool to go to federal court.
So, the arguments that I suspect that
the plaintiffs in this case, and this is
not a case I've been following greatly,
so if you think I got something wrong,
let me know. But the tools to go after
the NFA still exist. We have them in the
toolbox, but I'm not sure that the right
answer is to keep this one particular
case going, State of Texas Goa versus
ATF, as opposed to, let's say, go a
different route with a new lawsuit. Or
alternatively, you could potentially
file a motion to amend this lawsuit and
add additional claims under 42 USC 1983
to claim that the NFA, as applied to
these braces or whatever, violate the
Second Amendment andor violates Article
One. But I'm not sure you need to
because those lawsuits are already
pending in various courts across the
country, which we've covered. So the
bottom line is I don't think the fact
that the Trump Department of Justice put
out some pedestrian generic statement
that we're going to continue to reserve
the right to enforce the National
Firearms Act, which is an existing
statute. I don't think that means very
much. I think it's sort of saying
nothing really that we don't already
know. And again, if we want to take out
the NFA in various ways, I don't think
that using the APA or this in this
context is really necessary. I think
there's other ways for organizations to
chip away at the National Firearms Act
uh as opposed to this. So, at the end of
the day, I don't see this as a huge
deal. I don't see this as a huge story.
I certainly don't see this as evidence
that the Trump administration hates the
Second Amendment or anything like that.
Uh but again, if you guys think I'm
wrong, let me know. But this is kind of
how I see it. And since a lot of you
wanted me to cover this, I wanted to
outline kind of my thoughts on this and
why I don't see this as a big deal. We
won this case. We won this issue.
Fantastic. Now we go on and attack the
NFA in a different way, in a different
court, in a different thing that frankly
is already occurring. So, uh, I don't
think we're losing any ground here. And
as a practical matter, I'm not sure the
Trump administration is aggressively
doing anything with stabilizing braces,
uh, and going after gun owners that have
stabilizing braces attached to their
pistols. I haven't heard any evidence of
anyone getting attacked or gone after or
indicted over something, uh, that seems
a little squirrely, but if it's out
there, you guys will let me know and
I'll be happy to look at it. All right,
there you have it, folks. Hope you
enjoyed today's episode. Make sure you
follow me at x4box. Don't forget to
subscribe both the YouTube and the run.
I'll talk to you again real soon here at
the four boxes. Orders up. Table 2 A.